(audience applauds)
- Okay. You look so cute.
- Well, I put on a fresh outfit for you.
It's very fresh.
- It's like a rock and roll number.
I like it.
- It's sherbet.
Like a bit of a sherbet color.
- A sherbet.
I love your accent.
Well, the last time you were here,
you were talking about your son,
Rocco, right?
- [Rose] Yes, yes.
- Loves to like style you.
- Yes.
- Does this still happen?
He did makeup, right?
- He's been really into styling.
He did a lot of makeup
the other other day.
We had a birthday party
and he dressed my entire outfit.
He laid down my dress,
he put out the jewelry,
he did the shoes.
- [Kelly] This is my son.
- Really? Same thing?
- My daughter could care less.
My son is like,
"You should wear the sparkly ones."
Yeah.
- Isn't funny, yeah?
He was really-
And the birthday party
was at Chuck E. Cheese.
So it was like,
I was a bit overdressed for the party.
I had like-
- Like leaned in.
- Jewels and this and that.
I kept telling everybody, you know,
"I didn't choose this. This was-"
Yeah.
It was my first time at Chuck E. Cheese.
- Oh my God. How was it?
You didn't have Chuck E. Cheese
in Australia, right?
- No, we don't have it in Australia.
- So I grew up with Chuck E. Cheese,
so I'm very used to the-
- [Rose] Walk me through it.
I didn't know what was happening.
I was like, "Wow, this is a-"
- And the band is kind of crazy.
The animals that move slowly like this.
Yeah.
- [Rose] They're weird and the-
- Weird or cool.
- And when they put the kid in the tube
and the papers are flying around,
I was like, "What's happening?"
- Yeah, and the ball pit.
- Yeah. All that.
It's intense.
- Yeah. I love it.
I actually still to this day
still like the pizza.
- Yeah.
Well, Rocco said to me, and I quote,
"This is the best pizza I've ever had."
I was like, "All right."
- I don't know if it's nostalgia or what.
- Yeah.
- I take my kids there and I'm like,
"How is this still good?
I don't know what's happening."
- Yeah. Yeah.
They've really nailed the cuisine.
- It's just one solid thing.
Yeah.
Nailed the cuisine.
- Nailed it.
- So you've lived in New York,
is it 16 years?
- Yeah, 16 years.
- [Kelly] Do you feel like a New Yorker?
- I mean, I still feel like an alien.
I walk around, I'm like,
"What am I doing here again?"
You know, that feeling of being-
- [Kelly] That's kind of the cool thing
about New York.
You can be different.
- You can.
And it's like,
I still feel like growing up in Sydney,
I still very much feel
like an Aussie, you know?
But I think I could say I'm, I think,
what is it, 10 or 20 years?
I'm not sure what the time
before you can say you're a New Yorker.
- I think if you're there for a decade,
you can claim it.
- You think you can claim it?
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I do love it.
There's just nowhere like it.
- Yeah. I do love Australia though.
That was my first place to like visit
outside the States.
It's like a giant Texas.
- Yes. It is.
- I love it.
The people are just crazy cool and kind.
- I love southerners.
I find they're very laid back
like Aussies a little bit,
at least with space.
- I am too laid back.
But yes.
Is Valentine's Day big in Australia?
- It's not as big as it is here.
Here it's a big deal.
Yeah.
- It's definitely a greeting card holiday.
- Yeah. It is, yeah.
I'm still learning the ropes a little bit.
- My mom was cute.
She even like,
whenever I was a kid,
she even did like,
I'm shouting out to my mom,
she would put together a little like
Valentine's Day thing for me every year.
- She did?
- Yeah, she did.
Yeah, when I was kid.
And we were like poor,
so it meant a lot.
- Yeah, that is a lot.
Thanks, Mom.
- It was really sweet.
It's a huge thing here I think.
- [Rose] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Y'all don't celebrate love
in Australia?
- No, we don't believe in love.
No.
(Rose laughs)
- You're just like,
"It's kinda overrated."
- Yeah, no, it's terrible.
No, no.
The sentiment is lovely.
I'm getting better at it.
Like, trying to like get flowers
and stuff like that.
- [Kelly] I'm obsessed with flowers.
- Oh, me too.
I do love a floral-
- Me too.
They make me happy.
- They're joyful.
- I don't care if I'm a walking cliche.
Yeah. I don't care.
Leaning on in.
You posted a photo though,
with a guy we both love.
I love Snoop.
- [Rose] Come on.
- [Kelly] I forgot that
y'all had worked together.
This was back in the day, right?
- Yeah.
- Like, when was this?
- What's not to love about Snoop?
- I love him.
You're always gonna have a good time.
- [Rose] You're always
gonna have a good time.
We did this little indie movie
called "The Tenants."
I'm like 23, I don't know.
I'm so young.
And I played his girlfriend,
and he was such a gentleman.
We had like a dancing scene,
he told me I had good moves.
I asked him,
"Should I call you Snoop or Calvin?"
He said, "My mother calls me Calvin.
You can call me Snoop."
- Oh, he saves it for his mom.
- Yeah.
I was like, "Cute."
And then at the end
he gave me a huge blunt.
This massive joint.
- How was it?
- Oh, I didn't go near it.
I was like,
"I'll never, I won't recover."
I was like, "I can't."
So I gave it to my friend.
- Oh my God.
Did your friend freak out?
- They said they had a good time.
They had a really good time.
- I imagine-
Look, if you're gonna
take something from Snoop,
that would be the-
- Yeah, it was a fantastic,
it was like really brown paper-
I still remember how kind of sophisticated
this joint looked
compared to my-
- Do you regret not just trying a little?
- Maybe I do, Kelly.
You know what I mean?
Now that I'm thinking back,
I'm like, "Is that a missed-?
That's definitely a missed opportunity."
- [Kelly] It's in the story.
- It's in the story.
- [Kelly] It's just one puff.
I'm just saying, like,
if Willie Nelson or Snoop Dogg
hands you something.
I mean, I don't know, guys.
- Has he given you one?
- No, I'm very jealous.
But he did give me,
we worked together,
and he gave me this beautiful necklace.
Oh, it was beautiful.
- Oh, well that's romantic.
- It wasn't in a weird way.
No, he's very nice.
And he is like,
the best hype guy ever.
Like he makes you feel
so great about everybody.
Makes everybody feels so great.
- He was cool.
- Because he feels really good
all the time.
- And he's feeling good.
He feel the feels.
- It was funny though
'cause we worked together
and he just disappears.
Like every once in a while.
- Yeah.
And he walks back in and you're like,
"I know where you've been."
- I know.
- So the new movie is
called "Seriously Red."
And this is the first feature film
that you've done with your company, right?
- Yeah.
So I have a production
company in Australia,
Dollhouse Pictures.
And this is an independent
Australian film,
and it's really a love letter
to American country music.
It's about a tribute performer,
a Dolly Parton impersonator,
we say tribute performer,
and her finding her identity,
and I play a Elvis tribute performer.
My husband Bobby's in it
playing the manager
of these tribute performers.
And it's a really delightful,
heartwarming, funny,
full of the best music
coming straight from
your wonderful country.
And Dolly, who I know you know very well.
- And I heard that you actually,
before you even said you did the film,
you really wanted her blessing, right?
- Oh, well, we had to,
we had like, you know,
very little money to make the movie.
It's an independent film.
And so I got in touch with Danny Nozell,
her manager,
and I was six months pregnant,
and I drove to Nashville, Tennessee
and I gave him the script and I said,
"Please, can you get
this in Dolly's hands?
This is being made with the Hail Mary
and we need her blessing
to be able to make this film.
We can't do it without her."
Because her music is the narration
of the whole story and
character development.
- [Kelly] Which is incredible.
- [Rose] Yeah. Which is incredible.
And she read it and, you know,
a week later or so,
she came on board
and I finally got to meet her.
It took a long time because of covid,
you know, it was so hard.
And the film was in production
for so long development,
and she was amazing.
Yeah, yeah.
- She's one of those people that you want.
I tell everybody,
no, you want meet her.
She's awesome.
- You do you.
I totally agree.
- It's like, even better.
You think she's cool
and then you meet her and you're like,
"How are you cooler?"
- I know.
She's disarming,
she's so warm and down to earth,
and obviously she's this iconic-
- And she's like that
not only to like the
famous people in the room.
She's like that with everyone.
- Exactly. Exactly.
- Well, in the film,
I have to show.
You are the Elvis tribute performance.
- [Rose] Yes.
- [Kelly] Here is what you look like.
This is incredible.
Like, was that fun?
I was-
I think it's so sexy
when females do this.
I think it's so, so cool.
- It was so fun.
My best friend, Krew Boylan,
she wrote the script,
she's the star.
That's Krew there.
She plays Dolly,
and she said to me,
"I want you to play Elvis."
And I was like, "You got it.
I'm in. I'm all in."
And she's like,
"You got the same forehead."
And I was like, "Do we?
Great."
- What does that mean?
- I know. I don't know.
Facial recognition.
She has like a real kind of
intuition for that.
So we just went for,
I didn't wear any prosthetics,
I did a lot of contour,
and this great wig,
and these sideburns
and just watched so much footage.
And Bobby, my husband is,
again, he's really into Elvis
and he was reading an incredible biography
on him at the time.
So, I was pretty immersed.
Yeah, there's Bobby.
So, it was amazing.
It was very fun.
And, you know, I was an impersonator
so I didn't have to be, you know,
with that sort of caviar.
But it was very joyful.
A really fun experience.
- Yeah, a fun performer
'cause he sang with his whole body.
- Oh, he's just extraordinary.
The moves and the way he was just so-
Yeah.
There's nobody like him.
- Yeah.
Gospel blues, it's all in there.
Rock and roll. Yeah.
Was there a trick to
learning the Elvis voice
or moves?
Did you watch a lot of stuff?
- I did.
I watched so much footage,
and like a lot of old early footage
'cause that's the sequence
that I was kind of learning.
And it's amazing also
just the influence he had,
you know?
Like on everybody up to today
in music and in dance
and in everything.
He's sort of molecular,
the kind of effect he's had on music.
So, it was really, really fun.
Yeah.
- Well it's really cool
'cause both of those artists
I feel like, cover different genres.
They're not just like one genre of music
and they're very broad
and kind of connect with everybody.
- Yeah.
- What kind of music
did you listen to growing up?
- Um, what did we do?
I listened to-
- [Kelly] Did y'all listen to country
when you're were Australia?
- We did.
Well, Tamworth Music Festival
is a huge country hub in Australia.
There's a lot of country music there.
But I went through all the phases.
Like, I was like a 90s kid,
so I loved like Nirvana,
The Chili Peppers
and all that stuff.
I was deep into that.
Like, techno and all that kind of stuff.
- I was a mosh pit girl.
- [Rose] Yeah, me too.
I did a little of that.
I did a little of that as well.
- I got sweaty. Yeah.
Now it's not covid approved nowadays,
but yeah.
We were all sweaty and in there.
And like now I'd be so
grossed out by that.
I'd be like, "Get off of me."
When I was a kid I was like, "Yeah!"
- Releasing all those feelings
and those emotions
and all that pent up stuff
is like, nothing like it.
- And you look back and you're like,
"It really wasn't that big of a-"
- [Rose] I know.
- I really worked those hormones
for that situation.
Like, why was I so stressed?
There's a scene in the movie
where you get pretty drunk.
Are you method,
did you train for this or?
- Always method, Kelly.
Always method.
- [Kelly] I like it.
- I'm an Australian.
What did you think?
- I'm a Texan.
I can hold it too.
- You can.
- You hold it down.
(Rose laughing)
I'm always a big fan of tasting beverages
from around the world.
So, we got something we're told
is big in Australia these days.
So I don't know if we're correct
but Justin, thank you-
Thank you.
- [Rose] Hello, thank you, friend.
- It's orange wine.
Have you heard of orange wine?
- I don't care what it is.
This looks good.
This look great.
- All right.
Well, cheers.
- Cheers.
Thank you for having me.
Wow. Look at this.
Fantastic.
- Is it?
(everyone laughs)
- What do you think?
- It's alright.
It's a bit dry.
- [Rose] A bit dry.
What do you like to drink?
What's your-?
- Pinot or tequila.
And that's it?
- That's a song.
Let's write that country song.
- Let's go, let's chop it up.
- She likes pinot or tequila.